qui va traverser directement à travers
le terrain des sauts bienvenue au coeur
d'un des plus vastes terrain en friche
de l'île de Montréal son potentiel fait
rêver la mairesse de Montréal-Est ça
c'est top mon territoire une zone
industrielle de demain mais ce qu'on
veut c'est des centres de recherche des
écoles de Haute-Savoie les terrains à
vendre d'impérial hall font une fois et
demi la taille du parc Maisonneuve 53
hectares au nord de l'autoroute 40 mais
surtout un lot de 66 hectares entre les
rues Notre-Dame et Sherbrooke est aux
abords du port du réseau ferroviaire et
des axes routiers dans mes mots à moi là
je dis le silicone vallée du Canada
c'est sûr qu'on veut faire avec
montréalia c'est ça c'est mon rêve à
travers le pays des opportunités comme
celle-là il y en a très peu mais le
technopôle d'avenir ce but à un défi de
taille trouver l'acquéreur qui aura les
reins assez solides
les terrains vont avoir une valeur
au-delà du 300 millions les raffineries
ont été à l'origine de la prospérité de
Montréal est
le retour elles ont mis la clé sous la
porte depuis 40 ans on était à la
quatrième ville industrielle au Canada
ça a tout tombé avec la fermeture de ces
industries-là aujourd'hui c'est une
ville fantôme la rue principale
placardée n'est plus que l'ombre
d'elle-même les derniers résistants
comme cette pâtissière attendent le
renouveau avec impatience ça peut juste
s'améliorer les choses justement pour
éviter les abandons qui eux revitalisé
le quartier de revivre à travers tout ça
c'est que les terrains restent comme ça
puisse décontaminent pas et on va
bienvenue tout droit ça va être un
autoroute ici il faut faire preuve
d'imagination parce que les terrains ne
sont même pas raccordés aux
infrastructures de base dont l'aqueduc
avec un petit minibus c'est son côté
l'inexistence de transport structurant
l'avenir durant de l'Est étant devenu
incertain d'autant plus que la
décontamination se calcule en dizaine
voire centaines de millions de dollars
sur plusieurs années la première
opération s'est empêcher la disposition
de cette actif là à des développeurs
privés le président de la Société de
développement Angus plonge sur les
terrains des périodes depuis un an déjà
et on voit le potentiel il aura fallu 25
ans au technopolingus avant d'arriver à
un tel résultat un terrain qui ne
représentait qu'une fraction du chantier
de Montréal est le grand danger en ce
moment compte tenu lors de la grandeur
du terrain c'est que ça soit des
développeurs qui viennent y installer
des centres de données ou des entrepôts
puis là
l'économie du savoir ça faut oublier ça
là on craint que les sols soient trop
souillés pour de l'habitation mais la
vente des terrains bien alors que la
province a débloqué des millions de
dollars pour la décontamination l'est de
la métropole peut rêver d'un futur plus
vert ici Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada
Montréal est